el régimen de Daniel Ortega y Rosario
Murillo tomó por sorpresa en la noche de
este miércoles a decenas de opositores
que fueron capturados de acuerdo con las
denuncias consignadas en medios locales
y en organizaciones como la defensoría
nicaragüense de los derechos humanos se
trata de múltiples reales en diferentes
departamentos y se habla de que fueron
al menos 40 los detenidos entre
opositores líderes campesinos y
periodistas Uno de ellos es William
Aragón antiguo corresponsal del diario
La prensa de Nicaragua acusado de dar
noticias falsas también Maricruz
Bermúdez perteneciente al movimiento
madres de abril Ella es la madre de
Richard Pavón el primer joven en haber
sido asesinado durante la violenta
represión de las protestas masivas en el
año 2018 los detenidos fueron
posteriormente llevados a audiencias
judiciales en donde les imputaron los
cargos de traición a la patria
conspiración y menoscabo a la autoridad
y los jueces de estas audiencias Exprés
posterior posteriormente los dejaron en
Libertad bajo el principio de libertad
condicional pero con la obligación de
que diariamente deben asistir a las
diferentes delegaciones policiales para
firmar un libro el secretario de la
Comisión Interamericana el ex secretario
de la Comisión Interamericana de los
Derechos Humanos Pablo abrahau denunció
que Daniel Ortega necesita de presos
políticos como moneda de cambio y es que
esta es la más grande ola de detenciones
arbitrarias luego de la ocurría en el
año 2021 en el marco de las elecciones
generales cuando fueron detenidos en una
misma noche más de 30 opositores